holidays the Disney way the
entertainment Mega house usually finds a
way to serve up some big screen Family
Fun during Thanksgiving week and 2022 is
no different but what may surprise
moviegoers is the holiday box office
numbers coming in for Strange World
Disney Studios latest animated offering
the film follows the team who sets out
to find a solution to the danger that is
plaguing the world of Apollonia
apollonia's president Callisto Mal asks
Explorer Searcher clade for help as
shown in the film's trailers Searcher is
not thrilled about the idea telling
Callisto that he is nothing like his
father legendary Explorer Jaeger clade
who disappeared years ago while on
another Expedition despite his
reluctance Searcher still jumps in to
help his wife Meridian and Son Ethan
join him for the adventure along with
their adorable three-legged Legend while
uncovering the secrets of a strange
landscape Searcher discovers his father
and the adventure becomes a family
affair among three generations of the
clade family a Disney movie centered
around family seems like it would be a
popular Thanksgiving flick not to
mention that it boasts a star-studded
voice cast but according to reports it
still wasn't an not to send Strange
World soaring to the top of the box
office and loan numbers may have to do
with another big screen project in the
Disney universe according to the
Hollywood Reporter a strange world is
estimated to make just 19 million
dollars over the course of the five-day
holiday weekend according to Yahoo
entertainment the film's original
holiday projection was set at 30 million
dollars over the course of five days
which only makes up a slight chunk of
the 120 to 130 million dollars
reportedly budgeted for the animated
Adventure while not as many people
wanted to explore a new world with the
clade family as originally thought a
look at the box office numbers for the
movies playing during the holiday
weekend does prove that they did want to
see what happens next in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe black panther wakanda
forever is having a super holiday with a
film estimated to make at least a 60
million dollar gross over the course of
five days taking the number one spot at
the box office according to the
Hollywood Reporter the film first
premiered during the second week of
November closing out the fourth phase of
the MCU and ushering in a new era for
wakanda while the numbers paint a grim
picture for Strange World there are
other stats that could be considered
when when looking at its current Journey
on the big screen as noted by The
Hollywood Reporter a strange world has
received a B on Cinema score which is
the first time that a Disney Animation
film has received the cinema score below
an A in more than 30 years meanwhile the
movie's Rotten Tomatoes Tomato Meter
score is currently at 73 percent
looper's own review of the film gave it
a score of 8 out of 10 noting that
obvious dialogue and some less than
satisfying plot resolutions may leave
moviegoers feeling so-so about the flake
however the amazing visuals and plotline
about the importance of family are two
big positives according to the review
Yahoo entertainment Compares Strange
World to another Disney underperformer
Treasure Planet while it earned 16.6
million dollars during its opening
weekend it has garnered a lot of Praise
among fans with some calling for a
live-action version of the adventure
based on Robert Louis Stevenson's
classic book Treasure Island so maybe
Strange World will Garner even more
positive attention down the road
becoming a fan favorite for the new
generation